the Trump administration's top
intelligence officials have told
Congress that America's greatest
security threats are very different from
those seen by the president the global
threat assessment does not warn about a
crisis from illegal immigration despite
mr. Trump's claims about the southern
border intelligence leaders pointed to
dangers from Isis and North Korea that
the president has downplayed as recently
as this morning on Twitter we're well on
our way to get denuclearization and the
agreement says there will be total
denuclearization North Korea will seek
to retain its WMD capabilities and is
unlikely to completely give up its
nuclear weapons we have won against Isis
we've beaten them and we've beaten a
badly Isis will continue to be a threat
to the United States and they're the
largest Sunni terrorist group and they
still command thousands of fighters in
Iraq and Syria CBS News senior national
security analyst Fran Townsend was
homeland security and counterterrorism
adviser president george w bush fran
good morning morning first give me your
sense of the gulf here between the
president and his advisors and then
explain how such a gulf can exist well
so let's start with the good news the
good news is clearly the intelligence
community is taking seriously its
obligation frankly to speak truth to
power this can't have been the testimony
the president would have written himself
for the intelligence community oddly
enough you know just by the normal
bureaucratic process unclassified
testimony goes through a clearance
process and so the White House saw that
testimony before it was given and you
would have expected the president or his
aides to begin to shape this in a way
that didn't make the gulf between the
two so stark and one of the largest
gulfs was on the issue of North Korea we
just played it there we heard from
director coats we heard from Haspel who
leads the CIA that the nuclear threat
from North Korea remains the same in
fact Jena Hospital said North Korea is
committed to developing a long-range
nuclear-armed missile that would pose a
direct threat to the United States that
has not changed no I mean the
intelligence community acknowledged that
it's good that the United States and
North Korea continued to talk but what
they're not saying is that there's been
the progress made that the president has
suggested has been made there reports
this morning that the president had
unreported meeting with Vladimir Putin
private meeting once again at the g20 in
Argentina last year dan coates was asked
about the Helsinki the to our private
meeting the two of them had he said he
couldn't answer that an open testimony
that he would be able to talk more about
that behind closed doors what does that
tell you well you can be sure that when
Vladimir Putin goes back to Moscow he
does a debrief his intelligence service
is about what they're talking about and
to the extent our analysts aren't
understanding those conversations in
real time individually is a problem and
also the arc of those conversations
what's developing in the relationship is
there a relationship of trust all those
things factor into their assessments
both Vladimir Putin personally and
Russian policy during presidential
campaigns it's often said people say if
you don't understand the nature of the
threats you can't address them so this
disconnect here how danger is that
dangerous is that for American national
security look I think that this ought to
be a real frustration both for the night
not just to the American public but for
cabinet members right because the
cabinet members whether you're Mike
Pompeo at the State Department or Gena
Haskell or Dan Coates as you were
raining your your resources your arraign
them against the threats as you
understand them and so the ability to
communicate that to the president and be
sure he understands it's got to be a
source of frustration not not just at
the working levels of the intelligence
community but it more seniors so not
only a briefing about threats to our
national security was also threats about
to our democracy to our election process
we heard the head of the director of
national towns code say that these
adversaries are refining their
capabilities they are adding new tactics
for the 2020 election we heard senator
Warner also revealed for the very first
time that there was an effort during the
2018 election from unknown actors to
target our infrastructure are they
taking this seriously is the White House
on top of this so the most important
thing is certainly the intelligence
community there's a whole-of-government
approach right the intelligence
community takes the threat seriously as
we heard yesterday they work with the
Department of Homeland Security and the
FBI the testimony was pretty clear in
terms of what they could say publicly
that the mid-term attempt was
unsuccessful the concern is they're
gonna refine their tech
but the government is clearly organized
to try and thwart that in 2020 Fran
Townsend so great to have you here thank
you